hi my name is Marie trez and I'm singing
Pia Yuzu from Flores requiem
this Requiem is really a prayer
fundamentally and it's very special to
me because the words of the Piezo are
asking our lord for Spiritual rest
and I would especially like to sing this
piece for my mother who means a lot to
me she used to sing a lot and that was
her gift and when I was in third grade
my mom had news that she was diagnosed
with cancer and it was in her trachea
and she was faced with a decision that
the doctors gave her
of taking everything out and no longer
having a voice
or going in with a surgery which would
leave her with a voice but also
potentially with some cancer
and she chose the latter option so that
she could raise her kids with her own
voice because she still had a lot of
wisdom to give us
so I would like to thank her for all of
the sacrifice she has made for me
and I just offer up this piece for her
and pray for Spiritual rest for all of
us who are bearing crosses
I love you Mom
[Music]
thank you
please
[Music]
foreign
please
[Music]
foreign